to be clear I'm the one who paid the
tariffs China did not remember when the
Trump Administration slapped tariffs on
imports from China and insisted that
China would pay for them that's not what
happened the CEO of a US company that
sells HDMI cables recently told Congress
that tariffs made it more expensive for
her to import materials her company
absorbed the extra cost and made a lot
less money that's the exact opposite of
what the Trump Administration said would
happen China producers pay for these
tariffs they bear the burden of the
tariffs through lower prices lower
exports lower profits that's completely
wrong tariffs are really just taxes on
imported goods and who pays those taxes
we do by one count Americans paid 93% of
the Tariff costs and by the way those
tariffs are driving up inflation too
unfortunately President Biden loves the
tariffs and he's kept trumps in place
that means higher prices for business
owners and the rest of us